foreign
everyone my name is Dr Miller and the
SCP we're going to be looking at today
is scp-3005
object class
uncontained unknown
special containment procedures
scp-305 is to be located and contained
as soon as is possible site 17 is to
assume all responsibilities for
containment of scp-3005 mobile task
force mu-17 iron horses are to monitor
the region for signs of scp-305 presence
as a top priority objective and respond
to any such evidence immediately
recovered procedural information
scp-3005 is to be contained in a
soundproof enclosure at unit for testing
purposes
scp-3305's chamber entrance is to be
protected with an exposure foyer which
allows researchers to bring testing
items in proximity to scp-3005 Via a
remote chamber without exposure to
scp-305 emissions
any attempt at direct contact with
scp-305 must be made with mode veneroset
auditory visual Cognito counter and mode
Duba Thomas theological threat
countermeasures tonal dissolution
anchors under any circumstances
scp-305 in its pink state is not to be
engaged by fewer than 11 personnel if
cactuses are incurred during contact
with scp-3005 the bodies are to be
dissolved do not bury burn or remain in
contact with casualties incurred during
contact with scp-35
and recovered procedural information
description
information regarding the appearance
behavior and physical or metaphysical
properties of scp-3005 has been lost
unit the facility which housed scp-3005
is believed to have been destroyed
following a catastrophic Containment
Breach original containment document and
accompanying records were corrupted by
data loss or other means
scp-3005 was not present when Foundation
Personnel made contact with the site
following recovery efforts segments of
the original documentation for scp-305
are available to the foundation only
test log scp-3005 is fully intact and
cleared for unprotected viewing partial
containment procedures have been
provided however their reliability is
unverified
recovered testing information evaluated
but unverified
test log scp-3005
example entry
input describe object or entity exposed
here
distance describe the type of exposure
here
time list the duration of exposure here
output lists the results of exposure
here
and finally comment add relevant notes
or personal remarks here
testing researcher Dr
input 1 apple red delicious variety
distance Center of entrance foyer
roughly 5 meters time eight minutes
output Apple has been rendered partially
indistinct visually and to touch
comments it's hard to tell whether the
apple is whole cut ripe or rotted down
input to kilogram cube of ion distance
Center of entrance foyer time eight
minutes output no physical changes
detected block continuously vibrated for
approximately 64 minutes after exposure
comments the ringing was the worst thing
about this test I could barely think
while it was making that awful noise
eventually I got used to it when it
stopped I only noticed because the
discomfort went away
input one apple red delicious variety
distance Center of entrance foyer time
20 minutes output unknown comments I
have no idea what happened to the apple
or where it is
maybe it's in the chamber with scp-305
somehow
input to kilogram cube of iron distance
Center of entrance foyer time 20 minutes
output no physical changes detected
block could continuously vibrated for at
least five hours comment it sounded
better this time
input one d-class subject
695 241 distance entrance foyer time 8
minutes output viscera comments the
subject appears to have been flung apart
input one document encyclopedia
transcript containing basic factual
information about the species butiogymia
census distance Center of entrance foyer
time eight minutes output one document
variable comment
document might not be the right word but
I don't know what else to call it it's
like exposure to scp-305 shredded the
paper and left information behind
slippery trying to pick it up changes it
first it's a socialist political system
then it's a way to cook pork using
special equipment I managed to scrape it
into a bucket and stow it in a locker
when I check in on it a party game
stares up at me
input I'm on d-class subject
695-78 distance entrance foyer time five
minutes output moderate physical
distress non-lethal severe mental
distress comment she's a mess she threw
up a few times not in the game's bucket
and eventually her stomach calmed down
but she's still in shock over being
around that thing for so long
I cleaned up her fingers and she's
recuperating I'll call in a transfer to
psychoville
input one phonograph turned on distance
Center of entrance foyer time 82 seconds
aborted output
comments had to stop the test early
sound didn't get out of these but it
kept getting louder until I could feel
the music rattling the facility
I was afraid that it was going to bring
down the facility
input one d-class subject
695-22 to distance entrance foyer time
five minutes output severe physical
distress non-lethal comment I sent him
in to try and get as close to scp-305 if
possible touch it if he can and try to
make it respond he got too close but
refused to enter the containment chamber
itself he was babbling about how scp-305
wouldn't let him near threatened him to
somehow to send him somewhere else and
then be free you can tell he got too
close
I'll leave it to Medical to describe the
extent of the damage but emotionally
he's pretty okay
makes a lot more sense than the last one
actually did she ever get transferred
input one d-class subject 151 515
distance entrance foyer time 55 minutes
output viscera comment it turns out I
forgot to request a transfer for the
first subject I went to fix it but she's
not in the rest area I don't know where
she went this has been a rough couple of
days for me I've been sleeping in my
office lately because
I don't feel like leaving work
it's been almost an hour
more tests
input 25 kilogram cube of iron distance
Center of entrance foyer time 90 minutes
output no physical changes detected
comments
still ringing
input one one d-class subject
21 21-21
distance entrance foyer time to two
minutes output
moderate physical and emotional distress
comments we cleaned this one up and
helped them back up to speed
he'll recover fastest of all from the
pink light I requested the site transfer
bone though it is shown up here
input two d-class subjects
entrance foyer time five output severe
physical and mental distress viscera
comments this one was going to be
another regular test but the one from
the last time wanted back in
he didn't make it this time what was the
other one the one that flung apart I
remember their faces pretty well but I
don't think this one looks like either
of them
input one d-class subject six nine two
seventy eight distance entrance foyer
time five minutes output moderate
physical distress non-lethal it's severe
mental distress comment
they've been Restless the d-class
I call them d-class I could swear one of
them used to be Dr Watkins
need something to keep them occupied but
nothing makes sense to them anymore
everything except the betamax melted
into the floor I checked the tapes
I I checked the tapes and they are
Madness everyone keeps changing
should be enough to hold them at Bay
maybe now they'll stop playing that damn
record on the intercom speakers
input
to Max and VHS tapes books and compact
discs instance gathered around the
center of the entrance foyer time five
output 7 betamax type various variable
seven
comment just a repeat of the first
E-class test that worked
I copied over everything including the
d-class number
better than making them up
it's a completely different person
anyway I needed to replace the first one
because the new one told me she was dead
I asked him to deal with the body and he
said
don't worry about the body I'm surprised
because she wasn't flung apart and I
haven't seen anyone else in here in a
long while
who deals with the bodies is anyone
cleaning the test chamber
and put one power drill one distance
entrance foyer time not applicable
output three centimeter Gap in scp-305
containment chamber comments I needed to
do this they're all smarter than I am
well smarter really higher up I'm in
charge I'm the doctor but how long is
that going to last I keep getting
confused and look what they've been
doing with the staff turns out that
there's a good reason I haven't seen
anyone around lately
I guess this is why they terminate all
these guys after a month whatever's
going on I can't think about it right
now
I've seen the light and I'm
so confused
how did I know it was pink
input doctor distance opposite War where
the pink light lands time not applicable
output
is he comment
comments I knew I needed the pink light
but I didn't want it like they had it it
works on brains different from how
bodies work so I drilled a hole right
through the chamber right at the
forehead level let a shaft of pink light
shine straight in shimmering like
through water it hums when I touch it
which is the secret it reaches straight
in
dead it doesn't have to leave my organs
like apples
what I'm actually learning that doesn't
go here I'll be keeping a notebook for
it
input 1D class subject distance entrance
foyer time one
minute one one minute one
minute
one minute output
moderate mental distress moderate
physical distress
severe physical distress severe mental
distress
visceral
comments one of the other d-class I
don't have a number a database keeps
failing
they want it back in so I gave them a
minute at a time each time I asked for
more information about it eventually
they stopped making sounds
the pink light hasn't been helping but
probably I need more of it at least they
were flung apart
I heard the d-class caulking outside my
office when they thought I was sleeping
and they've been breaking in they've
been playing the game
and put doctor distance
the light time not applicable output
non-applicable comments these are not
the only worlds there are many times
and few worlds
and these are two of them I'm gonna
fortify it thought that the pink light
builds upon that it gives
you this other place your other self
forces them into you until you're flung
apart no
the pink light strips
away
takes from you
it takes that special part that keeps
you there in that first world brings you
here slight outshines Your Inner Light
until it's gone
I write in my notebook about scp-35 from
what I think it was made for and why it
began to give off the pink light and why
it can never stop I can't leave the
facility none of us can we aren't ready
for what's out there my notebook is
foreign
X camcorder running
distance Center of entrance for a time
five minutes
output
broken melted in space
the tape still works comments
video on audio off
good look directly now not too much
damage nobody here to read this maybe
d-class while I'm away but I'll need to
tell
director on Elvis hero anyone who can
tell everybody to stop using this all of
you they're Chained and lobotomized but
all it takes
on the shore but it's the last thing you
want to hold when you're drowning
then put one notebook
distance entrance for you time five
minute five minutes
output one religion
comment I like the diet is shining in
the water
input d-class subject
not applicable
distance containment chamber time
five output comments
they all went in they still had me do it
maybe they still respected that I was
hooked up
maybe they just wanted to leave me out
even if I'm half there already even if I
can't tell what is
there and
what isn't
can you
and I have a special plan I always
covered up the hole I drilled so they
didn't see it I have another way in
I know what I've forgotten there are no
more test subjects and nobody else there
is only one way in
the booth needs to be operated but I
have a special plan
don't worry about the body I just need
to know if my shaft I think light will
make me flung apart
input distant time output comments
up
father body
this concludes today's lecture
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are and you're all dismissed
goodbye
so I'm sure some of you like me are
slightly confused or have questions
about the document that you just
listened to so for occasions like this
I'm starting a new segment that I'm
calling extra credit where I can discuss
an anomaly without being confined to the
in-universe format you're all accustomed
to think of it as a fourth wall break
that serves to make this content more
accessible to everyone
in extra credit I'll typically be using
the work of people much smarter than me
to help explain an anomaly in this case
this person is modulum 83 from the SCP
Declassified subreddit links to the post
and modulum's author page will be in the
video description and if they would like
to leave a comment under this video to
promote whatever they like I'll pin that
comment and hopefully we're all happy so
scp-3005 a light that died
scp-305 explores the idea of horror in
two Fashions one through the usage of
classic word salad Madness and
dreamlogic and two the idea that the
foundation has no idea how to deal with
something
the basic idea in fact is very very
simple a Scranton reality anchor is
malfunctioning because it can't figure
out which reality to Anchor itself to
there are also tie-ins with fifthism
star signals and other lovecraftian
element but we're looking at this from a
decidedly confusing frame this story
about Madness bleeding into our world is
taken from an angle that forces us to be
drip fed hints about what's going on
adding to the tone of confusion and
eldritchness
here's what we know about the
containment procedures
scp-3005 has emissions and people must
be protected against auditory or visual
Cognito hazards total disillusion and
anchors
already then there are lots of hints
what this is getting at is that scp-305
is pretty dangerous it has radiating
dangerous effects on reality around it
that necessitate detailed containment
procedures and think about it this way
picture a Scranton reality anchor is
something that counter bends reality to
the foundation's idea of consensus
reality if you weren't part of consensus
reality this effect would be horrific
and jarring right
the testing log next describes what
happens when objects from our world are
exposed to the Anchor don't worry I'll
explain the fifthism connection when I
get to it
first they put an Apple 5 meters away
from the anchor for eight minutes what
happens is really unnerving Apple has
been rendered partially indistinct
visually and to touch
the rendering of reality is spazzing out
like a computer game
the block of iron the ringing was the
worst thing about this test I could
barely think while it was making that
awful noise eventually I got used to it
when it stopped I only noticed because
the discomfort went away
it's as if things exposed to scp-305
somehow become wrong in our reality it
adds a quality of notness to things
20 minutes of an apple and the output is
unknown a d-class for eight minutes
viscera they put a document in and
something really freaky happens
it's like exposure to scp-305 shredded
the paper and left information behind
it's slippery trying to pick it up
changes it first it's a socialist
political system then it's a way to cook
pork using special equipment I managed
to scrape it into a bucket and stow it
in a locker when I check in on it a
party game stares up at me
all these logs are trying to reinforce
one fact this object shreds everything
about our perception of reality the very
building blocks of logic that we are
based on are being broken apart by this
malfunctioning anchor oh by the way this
is where the fives start getting really
crazy that I might have missed in my
adaptation because it didn't really
translate that well to an audio
adaptation five five in Brackets minutes
one one in Brackets one d-class subject
one five one five one five fifty five
minutes
meanwhile the people working on the
scp-305 project are getting a bit crazy
and this is where we can now talk about
the fifth Church connection what is
fifthism based on what do they worship
there's no God but there is this idea of
a fifth world a level of Another
Universe gashes and cuts seeping Madness
into our reality we can't comprehend
exactly what it is a multi-dimensional
entity a glitch in the Multiverse but
all the same our world and the fifth
world are two planes of existence
mingling together and completely
incompatible with each other what
happens when you put two pieces of say
computer hardware or software that are
incompatible the data gets corrupted or
your OS goes crazy
that's what's Happening Here
the title a light that died references
star signals did you know that some
stars in the sky are dead but we still
see their ancient image the Scranton
reality anchor is a light that died but
also the idea that the ancient image of
fifthism and its indecipherability are
causing irreparable localized damage to
our universe
the Scranton reality anchor is now
exposed to two realities our world and
the fifth world the force of the fifth
world is so strong that it can't decide
which one to go with now it's
Transforming Our World into a fittest
ideal plane and all exposed to it are
having their brains messed with as this
Foundation site descends into madness
they've been Restless the d-class I call
them the class I could swear one of them
used to be Dr Watkins
need something to keep them occupied but
nothing makes sense to them anymore
everything except the betamax melted
into the floor I checked the tapes
I I checked the tapes and they are
Madness everyone keeps changing
but it should be enough to hold them at
Bay maybe now they'll stop playing that
damn record on the intercom speakers
throughout the testing logs there are
hints of this happening the information
is decaying into incoherency the number
five is appearing everywhere randomly
the researcher is talking about don't
worry about the body and I'm pretty sure
that d-class was Watkins oh well
then Dr blackbox Drills a hole in
scp-305's containment procedure as he
yearns for its pink light
I knew I needed the pink light but I
didn't want it like they had it it works
on brains different from how bodies work
so I drilled a hole right through the
chamber right at the forehead level let
a shaft of pink light shine straight in
shimmering like through water it hums
when I touch it which is the secret
it reaches straight into my head it
doesn't have to leave my organs like
apples
what I'm actually learning that doesn't
go here I'll be keeping a notebook for
it
this is made pretty clear in this next
log where Dr blackbox says these are not
the only worlds 3005 gives you Another
Place Another self it outshines your
inner light and replaces it
but I'll need to tell
a director or an Elvis hero anyone who
can tell everybody to stop using this
all of you they're Chained and
lobotomized but all it takes
catch the Serve Safe on the shore but
it's the last thing you want to hold
when you're drowning
the six letter black boxes anchor stop
using the anchors now that the anchor
has been exposed to another world that's
drowning the people hanging onto it
stop using the anchors
in the end Dr blackbox enters the
containment chamber something happens to
him changes him presumably and we
receive the only two cryptic creepy logs
at the end as an explanation
the author's explanation sums this all
up best by the way the author's name is
cell Barrister links in the description
but what happens when a Scranton reality
anchor becomes confused what happens
when a reality anchor encounters a
deeply strange anomaly that the
foundation doesn't fully understand one
that leaves it confused as to which
world it's in which reality it's
supposed to maintain or whether it's
still a universe at all what does it
seek to maintain when it's lost its grip
on reality
so this was the first episode of extra
credit
if this is something that you would like
me to do in the future let me know but
anyway I hope this helped
this concludes the second lecture
thank you all for listening if indeed
indeed you still are and you're all
dismissed again
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to
accept
Timothy
zargaron
Spencer are doing
rubbish bin 69.
broken sketch
Dr Wolf 13.
cubster
Spencer J telp
vinu
zazapan
Lemke
Dr Briggs
signor
Olive Treon
your local Foundation agent
derivative
Lost Boy
Lyndon B Johnson
oh crop guy
and James Saba
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the volgan
thank you
thank you